[Music]
foreign
VP of cloud AI industry Solutions and
I'm sudhir husband I'm senior director
of product management for data analytics
at Google Cloud the last few years have
led us to a Tipping Point with AI
adoption where we have seen the impact
of AI across more and more organizations
and more and more use cases
organizations for many Industries and
varying level of ml expertise are
solving business critical problems with
AI from creating compelling customer
experience to optimizing operations to
automating routine tasks these
organizations learn to innovate faster
and ultimately get ahead in the
marketplace
but how do they get there AI is hard
fundamentally hard
first challenge start with data it is
the challenge to manage this growth and
complexity it is a challenge to prepare
data for AI and ml usage
second AI expertise is scarce how many
AI experts do you need to get your first
model into production what about the
next set of use cases
and finally if you have all the pieces
in place the road from prototype to
production can still take months if not
years
how can you scale faster with confidence
I'm proud to announce the general
availability of big lake to help you
break the data silos and unify your data
lakes and warehouses
Big Lake will also support Apache
Iceberg which is becoming the standard
for open source table formats for your
data leaks and soon we will also add
support for other formats like Delta
Lake and hoodie our built-in support for
Apache spark in bigquery will allow data
practitioners to create bigquery stored
procedures unifying their work in spark
with their SQL Pipelines
as of today over 800 software Partners
power their applications using our data
cloud and 40 data platform Partners like
DBT data IQ and Tableau support bigquery
through certified Integrations
and customer adoption continues to grow
fueled by the ecosystem initiatives like
data Cloud Alliance
now we know 80 to 90 percent of data you
have today is unstructured this includes
your images your video files your audio
files today we are announcing support
for unstructured data in bigquery
through object tables object tables
enable you to take advantage of common
security and governance across your data
you can now build data products that
unify structured and unstructured data
in bigquery today we are announcing
support for unstructured data in
bigquery through object tables object
tables enable you to take advantage of
common security and governance across
your data you can now build data
products that unify structured and
unstructured data in bigquery
this makes bigquery One-Stop solution to
store manage and process all types of
data at global scale so in a nutshell to
overcome data complexity challenges we
are bringing lakes and warehouses
together with big lake and providing
support for open formats we are unifying
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data workloads into
bigquery
openness unification and Trust are the
foundation of intelligent data-driven
organization Google Cloud addresses this
challenge by offering a wide range of
capabilities that can increase the reach
of AIML to more users and help your
scarce resource your data scientists to
achieve greater productivity
organizations can start with our
out-of-box API like translation
transcription and many more where
developers can directly apply Google's
state-of-art AI to quickly solve real
world problems without the need to build
AI models themselves when you want to
work with your own data to build custom
models vertex AI offer a range of ml
tools to help you to build deploy and
manage ml models
this includes the ability to start from
scratch to create a fully custom models
were built on top of or one of our
existing models and then fine-tune them
for your particular needs starting with
bigquery ML a SQL interface that unlocks
ml capability for data analysts and
simple ways to be able to build and
train their models
as you have heard from sudir bigquery
will support unstructured data which
means bigquery ml would also work with
unstructured data you can now bring your
own model or use a model that's
pre-trained by Google directly on
bigquery object tables the results can
be stored and managed in bigquery for
further analysis or deplorative vertex
AI for real-time prediction for users
who want more control over ml
we recently announced exciting
announcement for automl workflows which
allows you selectively modify each step
in the model building and the deployment
process and be able to tweak custom
tweaks for for your automl and giving
you a more control working with automl
we will start with structured data and
expand support to unstructured data in
the coming months
tabnet is a powerful algorithm developed
by Google researchers that leverage
neural nets for tabular data today we're
adding tabnet to workflow to make it
easier for organization to work at a
massive scale without sacrificing the
explainability or accuracy
for some workloads faster is what it's
all about
I am excited to introduce vertex AI
Vision a revolutionary end-to-end
computer vision application development
service
that helps you to be able to reduce the
amount of time it takes to build
computer vision application from days to
minutes at a fraction of the cost was it
easy to use drag and drop interface and
pre-trained model for common tasks
vertex AI vision is the One-Stop shop to
build deploy manage computer vision
application so how did they get there
scaling data in AI across an
organization first requires strong data
governance and management and secondly
in order to move from data to AI
efficiently across use cases
organizations also need to streamline
end-to-end processes from preparing data
to building deploying and maintaining
machine learning models
further these capabilities we are
announcing various Innovations to
dataplex our intelligent data fabric
dataplex helps organizations centrally
manage and govern distributed data today
we are introducing
data lineage so you can get complete
end-to-end lineage from ingestion of
data to analysis to machine learning
models data quality will enable you to
gain confidence in your data which is
critical to get accurate predictions and
more importantly dataplex is now fully
integrated with big league so you can
now manage fine-grained access across
the organization at scale let's recap
for a moment we have discussed how our
data Cloud helps you unify data to
address the challenges of data
complexity and silos with this
organizations are well positioned to
adopt AI with built-in services for a
wide range of use users and use cases
this is critical to mitigating the
skills Gap Challenge and embedding AI
into your organization and finally
end-to-end data governance and
centralized ml Ops helps you scale AI so
you can address more use cases and drive
results across your business we hope you
have enjoyed the session thank you so
much for attending
[Music]
foreign